all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome Sharon yes Dania hey to the show
you guys were guests last night right
yes and how was your experience
yesterday it was good it was an
interesting interesting time it was
amazing it was very new to me because
I've never been on a podcast that's fun
though really cool experience have you
ever listened to that type of content
before yes you have okay okay what Have
you listened to
um I'm not sure if you've heard of B
Simone I think it's called the no for
sure podcast
I've also watched your podcast yet no no
it's in America okay yeah
so we make sure we're live really quick
sometime so I feel like put costs on the
new thing now so it's like you need to
switch the I need to switch the title
Pearl reacts with guests from the show
[Laughter]
um all right I need to
[Music]
Chris if you're watching please switch
the thumbnail please switch the
thumbnail soon I have a guy I don't make
thumbnails anymore I used to back in the
day so um I would say first we could
react
um
to the girl getting kicked out yesterday
yeah
um yeah because
I just was told later that you guys had
a horrible experience so I wanted to
make sure it wasn't horrible it was okay
you guys made it great okay wait let me
get the headphones
we gotta get the headphones
so you said you've seen my show before
have you seen any other like fresh and
fit
um Jordan Peterson no I just kind of
wanted to get familiar with it okay
I might have to grab headphones from let
me just make sure that's not a third one
over there
I might have to grab a third set of
headphones
um yeah the crew fourth all right it's
hot here I'm gonna give you guys the
chat
all right guys guys be nice in the chat
be nice let's take it over yeah so I'm
gonna go for like two seconds
um
yeah well it's not even on yet but
here's the chat you can see there I'm
gonna go grab a third set of headphones
[Music]
hey how are you guys doing what did you
guys think of yesterday's episode and um
give us your opinions
yeah I'm curious
follow me on Instagram yeah
Colombia yeah c-o-l-u shows on the vibe
yes follow us
they say anything I feel like where's
purple I'm not really no no yeah
hold on Terry yeah open those just so I
can get through
okay sometimes
we got Tech issues
I can't live without blessing
it's kind of weird when you hear it for
the first time right yeah you get used
to it though
through the headphones
let's see
all right so here now
see we're in the corner
and I gotta refresh it sometimes
oh my God
[Laughter]
uh let's see
why can I not hear this
oh my goodness we always have Tech
issues
um so you guys can't hear anything
either huh
[Music]
I can hear myself sipping this drink
let's see
you guys can't hear the audio at all no
oh we can hear ourselves but not that
not that yeah
I'll say sand help
now SOS
oh my gosh okay I'm just gonna keep it
playing and just see yeah
nothing if it picks up yeah nothing
what's wrong
headphones aren't playing
like something here saying off I don't
know if that has anything to do no
that's a different so that's if we want
to stream without sharing the screen
okay so that's like if we wanna it's
like a higher quality and this is if you
want to do a screen share oh okay but
this yeah so turn the interface very
techy on and back on
the static interface
a ring light
a ring light I don't just push the own
button
oh yeah so I was wondering is there
audio can they hear us
you hear us because maybe they can't
hear us
[Music]
um
the audio thing
blessings coming I want to see if they
can hear our audio
I feel like such a game ago I know right
oh they can hear us okay
um so I'll just asked you guys what what
was the most surprising thing you've
learned from like you learned from the
show yesterday
I think it was that statistic I can't
remember which one it was now so so
much use but um definitely I think it
was like the oh the percentage of men
that are over six foot tall is only 15.
it gotta be shocking it kind of makes
sense though when you think about it
yeah like because women are always
saying like men are trash yeah and all
that you know it's like oh they always
think they're dogs yeah we're the ones
yeah
literally yeah that definitely and it
was also good to hear other people's
views like a few
um a few things did actually change my
perspective on things men are actually
simple creatures I was saying this
earlier they don't need a lot what do
you think of blessing when he like came
in and was like asking the questions
what'd you guys think no I think it was
good to have a men's perspective I
actually do because we didn't have any
other obviously there was no men on the
panel and it's good to hear from the
actual mail point of view I understood
his perspective but I don't necessarily
fully agree with it would you not agree
with I don't agree with the fact that if
I have something to say I should be like
just I get the submissive part but I
just don't think it's like right for me
not to have a voice or not to have a say
yeah but it's understandable I
understand it but you know I do think
though I think the point he was trying
to get across is yeah if you're with
someone in your mouth you guys have the
same views you're not going to really
disagree you should right yeah you
should there's not going to be much
disagreement now because if you disagree
on everything or your question
everything then you guys aren't really
compatible I was curious what was it
like growing up in a multi were your
parents religious or they weren't
religious my mom was religious my dad
was kind of religious I mean he wasn't
really yeah he was he was just like open
the Quran clothing because just give him
a background your your mom is what and
your dad as well so my mom's Nigerian
and my dad is from Iran so he grew up as
a Muslim and a bit spiritual as well and
my mom grew up as a Christian and
spiritual as well so they had like yeah
both of those but my mom has always been
really open-minded to other religions so
has my dad and that's why I feel like
they that was already yeah that was
already like an open gate for them to
get to know each other
um I moved around a lot countries wise
so I was born in Germany uh oh shut up
[Music]
yes but I also lived in Nigeria and that
was a complete switch of like scenario
and environment and it was just you
lived in Nigeria for eight years really
wow so how old were you when you moved
you moved I'm I was eight years old and
I left when I was 14 or 16. no way do
you think that was good for you as a kid
no no very traumatic yeah extremely just
chaos
but I don't blame anyone for that I feel
like I just need to learn and grow yeah
I guess because you're moving around so
much you have to like leave all your
friends and when you're younger you're
not you have to like re-adapt and like
build new friends then you move from a
complete different country you kind of
lose those connections exactly so it's
like starting fresh each time it's a lot
when you're younger because obviously
when your friends mean so much to you
yeah when you're older you can kind of
pick up anything exactly but
14 where'd you go from 14 here I'm here
yeah she lived in three wow that is so
incredible how many siblings did you
have three sisters was it easier because
you had the sisters at least oh they
made they made life
so much easier okay keeping up with the
Kardashian was like a religious thing
for us
like every I think Saturday or Friday or
whatever it was we would like come
together as a family and watch it again
just for the sake of like having that
family time not even paying attention to
what was watching just having that
closeness was very important
because I can't imagine doing that as
like an only child or like two kids like
at least I I came from a big family I
had nine siblings total so it's a lot of
us but I'm like I can't imagine three
countries no siblings yes culture shock
as well because yeah and I'm a big
family person out of all of my sisters
my mom I'm the biggest like I'm the most
attached to my family and so what
country was your favorite to live in
Germany because I didn't remember a lot
yeah and I still had my dad around there
but as we moved to Nigeria things just
got absolutely just
horrible wait your dad wasn't around in
Nigeria he did combo he was like in and
out of prison he was just like I was
affiliated with guy your dad present
yeah oh my God you should write a book
is he still right where is he now oh you
don't know can you just vanished
disappeared off the face of the f
literally yeah crazy do you think that's
affected like you're dating and
relationships and your ability to like
understand men it's affected
everything I know to be Humane because I
I
always try to put myself in people's
position and just like see things from
people's point of view
um obviously with my mom I grew up very
much with her like from what I remember
it was all my mom my mom was my dad my
mom was my mom my mom was my grandpa my
mom was my grandma so she filled in that
role but emotionally I don't think she
was there it was more like work
keep the kids safe work keep the kids
safe because just listening to your
stories I kind of sense that maybe there
wasn't a dad in the picture just because
like when you're describing your ex I'm
like there's no way
yeah you're right yeah I definitely
think having a father figure than
present has a huge impact on the type of
men you go for 100 especially when you
see how your dad treats your mum yeah
has a huge impact on how what you accept
as in the dating because you're
especially you you're naturally very
feminine like because some girls come on
and they like act like dudes beer you're
not like that you act like pretty
feminine and that's because I've not had
a voice for so long yeah I was I was so
quiet I was anxious I was scared of
everything and anything because of how
much trauma I had been through in my
life so I felt like everywhere I went
was like a danger zone like I have to be
on God come in thank you
[Laughter]
we're live yeah
oh [__]
he's like wrong time the screen
recording isn't the audio like the audio
is picking us up but we can't do the
screen yeah like when we play the video
we can't hear it in the headphones
yeah
girl
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
left him
able to come downstairs yeah yeah of
course yeah I'll take one of you who
wants to see I don't mind yeah that's
right I mean I'll go because you guys
have had like a more of a conversation
okay yeah
hi guys bye
I have a question
what's up why do you well why do you
make these so long oh well because what
was it the green it's like
thinking I was like she actually is very
pretty and actually I was like I think
men would actually like like her but I'm
like why do you mark it like this is
like horror nails
and bad advertising well I don't get my
nails done very often and I was I went
to Germany recently to visit myself and
so I was like you know yep it's like you
can do it right here
not my real dad but yeah the and it's
like the the eye the green yeah you look
like a different person I was like what
the why did she do that
actually I love it I love it I love to
just I don't know just
don't expect anything from me don't
expect what do you mean I'll be
spontaneous like I'm very
yeah okay we're gonna show you freaking
um all right
I actually don't really feel like giving
this girl more Cloud I'm gonna show you
something else
um I'm gonna show you you know Jordan
all right do you believe in the pay Gap
do you believe women are oppressed yes
or no
um
I feel like women feel oppressed yeah do
you think we are oppressed yeah yeah
okay I'm gonna guys
I hope to God that this doesn't
sometimes YouTube copyrights me
can you let me know in the chat guys is
YouTube gonna copyright this one I want
to either do this one or cat oh shoot
they can't see it I want to do this one
or Kathy Newman but I feel like Kathy
Newman gets copyrighted and I don't want
the stream to go down so um let me know
in the chat which one should I show her
which one
um yeah this is what they're saying they
said she is too pretty those Nails in
the green eye makeup
so I'm saying I was like she came in I'm
like who's a different person
it's like why would she do that
oh thank you I appreciate it
as
all right oh you guys want me to show
her average at best do you know Kevin
Samuels I did okay I'll show you please
do oh this guy's so funny I know Kevin
Samuels won't get copyrighted oh my gosh
I've seen this video so many times this
is okay so in the manosphere is like
men's Centric content okay so and Men's
Center contact they'll talk about things
like dating advice right and a lot of
times like the men what they would do is
they'd come to women and tell us what
they really think because there's a lot
of stuff like submission you probably
never really heard that before and so
this guy Kevin had a call-in show that
was the most oh my gosh yeah it was so
funny have you ever seen him no no never
okay okay those were hers
hey can you hear me yeah are you a PhD
I know I'm a PhD how many dollars you
got one
really
I'm sorry what kind of dog is it
he's a Cane Corso
he's a what a Cane Corso what is that in
English
um It's a larger dog and their breed is
meant for gardening and protecting and
they're very protective of their home
and their family okay so what's your
disagreement
I don't have a disagreement I just came
here because I honestly want some advice
from you
it says disagreement day I know but this
is my first time catching on live
normally I'm asleep and uh you have a
job
I do I own a business okay so I do too
and I do have a question but I have a
business and if you wanted my advice you
could always book a session if you can't
catch us at the show live I'm definitely
I was trying to go online
on a pet grooming Doggy Daycare okay so
what you're basically trying to do is I
have a disagreement day and you
basically came in and said damn your
topic I want to ask you what I want to
ask you and that's but you're more than
welcome to go on my website and purchase
your time to talk with me one-on-one
because what you're trying to do is
rather rude but I will go ahead and do
it do you think he's right yeah yeah of
course now this woman didn't know she
was about to sign up to be an internet
sensation because he wasn't that big at
this point okay but this this video
broke the internet you'll see why you'll
see because I'm going to use this as a
teaching lesson
how old are you I'm 35. 35 years old
35 years old and you're a business owner
uh-huh and what's your question
um so my issue is well I want to know at
what point when I'm
just meeting a guy do I tell him that
I'm a business owner because
um my problem is that when I try to date
down and I the conversation comes up to
where I own the business
um the guy is either like hey can I come
join in on you on that business or can I
put somebody and be a business partner
and
I'm not looking for that and I honestly
oh oh hold on hold on hold on hold on I
need to be clear on this subject where
are you where are you at North Carolina
and you're saying when to tell somebody
you own a business
because
um I find when I date down guys to your
interest and want to be like a business
partner and um I'm learning that maybe I
need a high value man because that's
what well first off
um
ma'am I really understand uh what kind
of man are you talking about
because owning a business is no
different than having a job in my
opinion
I'm not getting what you're saying when
should you I'm not understanding why
this is an issue what do you think so
far yeah because it doesn't really make
sense what she's saying what do you mean
like whenever whenever you feel
comfortable telling them you own your
business just tell them well just don't
tell them since you see that the results
if I didn't want to tell someone what I
did I just say oh I work in marketing
you guys don't care
is it really that it's never that
serious for her to come onto his show at
this point knowing that it's a it's what
is it
blue hair I do why would you do
it it's weird guys
I do I do have new hair
you just noticed that oh my gosh you
guys
I do oh my gosh can we dye it back
you know what it is
polycystic ovarian syndrome causes my
hair like to like I get I lose hair I
lose a lot of hair so then me dying is
like why not make it more
like
poppy
it's really sad it might feel a little
bad for you oh
me too but can we die I'll pay for it
I mean
I can definitely
dye it back it's okay that's not being
used
is it okay yeah hopefully
but yeah I'm just gonna
cover that up just ignore it just it
never existed
if you're if you're I'll do this to my
sister
what kind of man are you dating
I've never had a guy care and I I I have
a business
to join my business like does that even
make sense do you date men with no jobs
that's a question oh
um I tried to give I try to give guys
that not serious you try to do what I
try to give guys that's not on my level
a chance why what do you mean on your
level what does that mean that's making
six figures or more
but I don't under okay you try to give
guys who are not on your level a chance
wow
because I want I honestly want a six
figure guy
um is what I realized okay so let me
just go ahead and net it out for you
you ready uh-huh
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well I'm I haven't been to put myself
out there honestly
but you put yourself out there enough
for the guys you don't want or relieved
you to ask you out
those are like guys I met online
right so again
the men you want are not asking you out
See you ladies do this
you go and deal with men who you feel
are beneath you and then you ask how to
fix them I'm not beneath you I don't
know how to fix a guy that doesn't
that's down there that's not my concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real question
well first of all I would tell you what
I said in here automatically is a
problem
why you would come onto a show that you
know was a disagreement day
it's selfish
it's like well yes ma'am it's so it's
like I want what I want
I don't get I don't say things for no
reason
that's why I asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner that means
you understand what business is and you
know this is a business and I have a and
I have a show title and you said damn
your show title I want to talk to you
but you could have went to my business
and book time to talk to me but you
wanted what you wanted how you want it
I'm sorry no it's but and I'm using this
as lessons
I'm sorry do you feel embarrassed this
is like what people would always say he
was harsh right no but he's being honest
he's being honest that's like yesterday
like when we were talking about the
following yeah and everyone was like
well well he shouldn't be following
those girls and I'm like but why did you
find it in the first place yeah and
that's and then it just shows you crazy
it's okay I'm getting crazy like it's
I'm not saying I'm not saying I'm above
it
I'm just like we just gotta you gotta
identify the problem in order to fix it
yes but it's like why is women can we
never hear criticism for men or women
without it being too emotional
she knows she grew up in Nigeria guys
she's based
exactly yeah it's a problem with too
many of you black women you don't do
[__] the right way with black men
that was improper and when I even when I
told you the right way you still were
like uh well whatever
so I'm gonna use this
when was the last time you had a
relationship
um like the end of last year around
December how long did it last a year
a year uh and was that man uh did you go
to college
did I go to college
yes
I think I don't remember I think she
says no and I always know when girls
repeat questions back to you yeah that
means they don't want to answer guys
guys hold on I need to read a Super Chat
Charlie Brown she's back in the chat
let's give a Charlie Brown yay Super
Chat are you you and your content how
can I become a member I intend to join
your event in shy town since you won't
be coming to the Twin Cities anytime
soon okay so oh my gosh I need to put my
link in the chat okay I don't want you
guys seeing what's going on on my
computer you know
um but guys we are doing a meet up we
are doing a meet up in
um what do you call it in Chicago I'm
going to a bunch of cities for some
podcasts and you know looking at cities
to move to we're going to be going to
Chicago We're going to be going to
La we're also going to be going to Miami
and
um Nashville so if you want to be
notified make sure you sign up for the
email list it's in the description or
it's in the I just pinned the comment in
the chat
if you want to be a part of my
memberships okay that lets you be a part
of the live chat
um you can see behind the scenes Vlogs
one-on-one call with me once a month All
That Jazz
that you go to my page and click join
memberships um I
know
not putting your phone your email you'll
be texted when I'm in different cities I
won't bombard you I swear we're also
okay you know I call fat chicks whales
you do yeah I do
um it's because they are
and I'm afraid of them anyway
I'm afraid of the fatties so so oh
no beasts only obese you know chubby is
okay but obese I can't I'm just I'll
just hide under my bed but
um anyways
we're gonna do some whale merch so it's
gonna say I'm gonna have the types of
whales and then it's gonna have like a
beluga whale and then it's gonna have a
fat chick in the middle
but I can't sell that on YouTube so so I
gotta I gotta sell it somewhere else you
know what I mean that is genius
um yeah so if you guys want that sign up
for the email list to be notified I'm
trying to figure out the marketing stuff
someone else said saint Sarah red pill
her Pearl look at guys
I'm a red pillar okay she's never gonna
see the world the same after I'm done
with her you wait you wait maybe not
this episode once she sees Jordan
Peterson it's over
okay and how long have you owned your
own business
nine years
and how and how long have you been
making six figures or more
on the last three
okay why do you need a man making six
figures
um because I'm finding out that the guys
that I date that's not is not working
out
what does it have to do with money oh my
gosh I put the wrong link I put the
wrong link guys that is not the right
link I just realized okay hold up I
don't wanna I wanna show you guys the
stream here nothing now
gotta delete this one
I'm sorry guys I'm sorry okay here's the
actual link I fixed it okay
Place pinned messages okay my bad guys
my bad all right now back to the video
sorry
yes
because I feel like
um I need a guide that I can respect and
admire and I'm a [__] ambition and I
want a guy that has that drive too and
when he doesn't I find myself you know
encouraging like hey babe you can do
this and you can do that and then all
right so in North Carolina
how what percentage of the population
what percentage of men in this country
make six figures or more what do you
think that is
six figures in the US is like 80 000
pounds here and it's roughly the
percentages are similar okay
I have zero tree I'm not going to lie I
would say
what percent yeah of men make that much
money
is that a lot is that too much that's
way too much
you're really awesome
it's like not even close
some of social media does I think all
these people the average salary is like
40 like 45 really thousand I think in
the US I think here it's like 40 000
pounds or something like that I think
it's five five percent I'm not trying
closer to ten so oh 10 all right so the
question is what do those men who make
that kind of money who all women tend to
want
what do they want
I feel like they want arm candy somebody
who can um have more to bring to the
table than just looks but
um also bring balance to their life I
feel like I can help them out on um okay
slow down I'm not understanding you said
they want arm candy then you
contradicted yourself
do you want what they want somebody to
do more than just looks
yeah arm candy but something behind you
know brain with
the devil you
know do you mean who make six figures or
more
my dad and my uncle
do you
tease me do you know any men that you
are related to that make six figures or
more
unrelated to yeah that you are not
related to
not on a personal level
so you don't know them
you don't know what they want but you
want him man
I'm going to suggest that you really
don't know
what you want
and saying six figures is just something
that you've got taken from out there but
I'm not hearing this rooted to anything
what do you want ultimately do you want
to be married children what
yes I want to be married
do you want any children yes
how many
um
I have a son now so
how's your son he's 13. where's the
father
he's not enough in his life
I say where's the father
well he's
not like in it like I would like him to
be
all right so
um go ahead and take this down man
who make the kind of money you're
talking about have options
and typically I don't want to deal with
women who are have 13 year old sons who
are used to dating Men Who
this doesn't sound appealing
is he right or wrong he is right
right because as he said there's
that six figure man wanted to go and get
someone that is his preference without
that child and without those issues that
she's talking about he would yeah freely
happily going over easily yeah did your
mom find did she date after your dad
yes was it hard for her having kids yeah
especially four girls yeah oh that's a
hard sell oh boy just four girls all
right I'm trying to like because I think
about this stuff like if I had a girl
like how I would package her to the men
so when you come in with the hair
but I don't know you're into girls
apparently so how did you know that you
said you hooked up with this oh
oh so but I feel like women oh yeah I
feel like we're all I feel like women
I feel like are you full-blown lesbian
or just like a half
I feel like
Sometimes women become lesbians because
they're traumatized you think so yeah I
think they're not really lesbians
sometimes you don't give me real lesbian
energy really yeah you're too feminine
that's because it takes me time to open
up I this is me like when I want to be
presented in front of when we see
something pop
behind closed doors I'm wearing a
t-shirt I'm wearing like children it's
not about it's not about your clothes
it's about your attitude oh yeah it's
like when I talk to you you're not you
don't have that like masculine I'm not
saying I just have the scary you can
tell me if I'm wrong I could be wrong I
have a lot of theories right I have a
theory that women will become lesbians
or bi after a traumatic breakup or
because they're just so sick of men or
when they get to a certain age where
they can't get the men they want anymore
so it's like they go for the 20 of men
right tall good looking and once they
can't get attention from them anymore
then they'll start dating women it's
like around 30 usually roughly they're
like
oh
because they would rather be with a girl
than a guy they don't like and they feel
like girls are more understanding
yeah yeah what's your experience dating
men versus women oh well I've never
really
you've never dated a girl oh okay but I
have spoken to girls and I I have found
myself more attracted to girls weirdly
enough more it'll I feel like you'll go
back we think so yeah we need to fix her
we need to do some conversion but that
came from when I was really young I've
always found girls like
appealing most girls do most girls if
you like um survey like if you survey
them or whatever like they did some
tests most girls are attracted to girls
really to some level I mean it doesn't
mean that like have sex yeah but like
but you know I come with a sister
I mean
it's all right it's right we all got we
all got troubles we all got in trouble
but but I feel like yes that sometimes
girls it's like a phase and then they'll
go back to the guys yeah so I'm like
that you're not too far gone we're gonna
bring her back
oh really we're gonna we're gonna
to the kind of man you're talking about
do you understand what I'm saying
yeah but um I was thinking once I start
booking section with you
man I know but I can approve myself
would you expect me to do that
I'm so hell what you can't undo a child
I feel like she's sort of answering her
own questions as well in this interview
she's allowing herself to
like see things from a different
perspective in terms of now you're being
questioned you're not asking the
question you're being questioned so now
you it's like the answers are coming out
unwantedly if that makes sense
I feel like I have a lot to offer to
those type of music okay but see
you should have stopped right there
I just told you I cannot change men and
you said once I book a session with you
I'm not a miracle worker I'm telling you
what they want and you're still saying
yeah but I want this what'd you say I
said don't expect anything crazy like
I'm not gonna like Snap and you have a
secret man in front of your door you see
why they say women are delusional yes
this is delusion
like okay if you were like 22 25 we can
work with it yeah we can work with it
all right but with the child yeah yeah
that's a big that's a big good luck
especially because guys or I think he
might talk about this guys will judge
you by the guys you've dated before so
it's kind of like if they say you made a
kid with someone and he's not in the
picture they're like why like what did
you you know it's like it's not fun but
it's like either you can't pick and you
like the bad boys and you're not going
to be satisfied with the nice guy or or
it's like why didn't or you're too like
you don't you won't let the dad see the
kids it's like another thing that they
you know oh well so like when girls will
talk bad about their exes I'm like cry
you guys are telling them
stop they don't you dated this man
but I have been working on myself this
year and um
okay ma'am but okay 35 13 year old son
with a sketchy father why would a man
who's in the top 10 percent of earners
who women across the country
want want that
um because I have a lot to offer
um I feel like would you want your son
to
you had a son making that kind of money
would you want him to bring home a woman
who had a 13 year old son from a sketchy
father or would you prefer him to get a
woman who had no children he was younger
and easier to get on his program
depending on his age
see what I mean see what I mean this
goes so deep for black women
they will even that should have been an
easy question no I would not want my son
to bring I want the best for my son that
should have been the appropriate answer
that's why I sat up
that is [__]
you should want the best for your son
Taurus but this is
but
and are you thinking
yes I feel like I'm the setup
that's a problem you all think you're
the exception to the rule but but your
life is proven to you that you're not
my love life is not that good I agree
with you because that's my point and
ma'am and that's my point you ladies all
feel like listen
you ladies all feel like you're the
exception to the rule
and then when someone like myself comes
along and gives you a a dose of reality
instead of just accepting it it's like
yeah but yeah but I'm special
you don't know any men on this level
but are not your father that aren't
related to you that means you don't know
these men you don't know where to go get
them you don't know what they want
but you're still saying pick me they
don't want mid 30 year old baby mamas
are trying to be polite man but they
don't want those
I ask you a question
did you hear what I said
[Laughter]
do you think
baby mama
I don't I don't really mind people
wanting what they want right you can
watch what you want but it's just like
be logical but it could be reasonable
like okay if he has to accept a kid from
you you can't accept I don't know 45
000 a year you know at least
maybe even go lower
anyone she was talking about like oh I'm
educated I'm like you don't sound
educated the way you talk like
[Music]
why is that so okay go ahead
he's given up
go ahead
um
my from my point of view I feel like I
get what you're saying they they do have
better options but also those better
options are younger girls
those younger girls don't necessarily
are necessarily 20 year olds are not
necessarily attracted to 45 year olds
true or false false
what I I very much
man
yeah
big big full I think I was 24 when I
first saw this and I was like
older women shame younger women or shame
men for wanting to get with younger
women yeah do you think older women
sabotage younger women thousand percent
yeah why do you think they do that
because they feel like because they've
wasted their own youth
they now feel like okay you know what I
I can't have that you can't have that
either have you ever heard them I think
I the one that makes me mad this makes
me mad when I hear older girls trying to
tell younger girls that they should
sleep around and like do whatever they
want because you know damn well that's
right and I'm like there's nowhere 35.
yeah you have gone through life and
thought hmm being a [__] is the best
outcome now you can have your how long
to wait thoughts you know you could you
could people will argue but you know
damn well being a [__] it's not that's
not ideal and I'm just like that makes
me mad because they know better and
they're lying and I just hate I hate
liars
and it's like let's get this bag like
you missed your chickens please
[__] also wait uh welcome Scrappy
mark and
um
but who else has joined the memberships
uh Saint sir the cheeks McGee that's a
great username and Doug MPI if she dates
women long enough she will go back to
men you can see stud lesbian content
creators on YouTube saying that modern
women expect too much to avoid single
mothers yeah she'll be I I can feel it
she'll be back to the men but welcome
everyone yes okay again guys there's so
many people you watch YouTube when do
you donate
um do you ever donate that's okay that's
what I'm saying they don't even have to
donate and I have the best fans they're
so nice like they send donations when
they could just watch for free yeah you
guys are the best anyways back to the
show you one and I can't beat them off
with a stick
that's another one on you lies no
younger women do you think he's hot
I can't really see his face you can't
see it from what you see his mentality
is very attractive very like the way he
speaks and so direct yeah at that point
no wasting time don't it does it kind of
make you not trust a guy when he says
what you want to hear too much like if
he's like oh you're so beautiful you're
the most beautiful girl and you're just
like yeah I know tell me something I
haven't heard
tell me something happened it's like one
thing is if a guy says you're beautiful
too much and I know guys that they're
all gonna be like modern women but okay
if they say like you're the most
beautiful woman in the world it's just
like I know I'm not yeah so why are you
as well and I feel like this the
mentality is stuck
in like the teams yeah mentally grown
well they're like trying to please women
yes and it's like he he doesn't give a
[__] he doesn't he's giving a [__] about
what's right yeah what's like
welcome welcome
also guys to learn about to do our
meetups we're gonna do meetups in each
City I want to match make people we'll
get you know I'm gonna find her a minute
I'm gonna get rid of these nails we
gotta do some work we gotta get her
clear yeah yeah not a woman not a woman
that's her wrong her wrong her wrong
I'm homophobic just so you know
homophobic big homophobe so yeah any of
the lgbtqs get them out of here I mean
they can stay I'm just afraid of y'all
distance social distance
[Laughter]
when younger women are attracted to the
older men what are you talking about
so can you see me
yes I can
okay so do you feel like a woman like me
what would you rank yourself on a scale
from one to ten you cannot use seven
what I rate myself just your face
um my face when I wake up five but when
I put myself together six
okay what would you give her
I think that's
you know that's not it
I think she rated herself good but from
my perspective
my definition of view is what's on the
inside I know it's like oh but okay by
looks we're not talking about okay okay
okay back to the topic yeah so five is
average five is not an insult it's just
a normal location
I would have given her a four four to
five hours and done up five right yeah
okay
cool and how tall are you
high five dress size
I'm sorry would you go on a date with
her
no no
[Music]
I have my times
first size
okay so that makes you
if you give yourself a five that's
average
yes
so average looking women
tend not to get
High earning men
they tend to get average men
so
um did you did you I mean stop right
there stop right there
stop right there breathe and digest yeah
truth like honestly like there is
something as pretty girl privilege or
whatever it's called
okay you do it 35 years old and you can
look around and see the world
you don't tend to see higher earning men
with average looking women
off rip
if you do see them they got them they
got their average looking woman when
they were both really young and he built
his way up exactly but a man earning
exactly unless you knew her from like a
young age then there's no chance and the
girls will look at those guys like
they're lame in high school and they
won't date them yeah and then they're
mad they can't get them later like my
dad he's a like top one percent earner
right my mom started dating him when she
was 17. really and um they my yeah my
mom
um he was a nerd oh like yeah he was
nerdy guy yeah
let's see someone you're talking about
does not go for an average looking woman
I mean my body is not average so but
you're ma'am you please don't make me
say it
you're ugly
I really just wanted some advice I love
you I'm giving you I'm giving you advice
but you're not taking it the advice is
man man
your average looking at best
I'm taking it in but okay but you're not
accepting the fact that okay
average looking women
average looking woman who's older
average looking older woman with a 13
year old son
average looking woman with a 13 year old
son with a sketchy baby daddy
this gets worse I hate when she's on her
phone
it's like you you're pissed yeah she's
offended she's hot she's obviously
because in the beginning she didn't come
on with her phone so why is she on her
phone now yeah
oh we got some super chats okay thank
you Matt butcher
uh this type of content is essential to
counter toxic social takes thank you for
appreciating us ladies that's all it
takes appreciate your man what your man
does for you and your family Doug
this is that you
thank you for leaving thank you for
leaving the green makeup at home really
do you think men like green makeup I
think maybe the women do do you think
men men like green makeup
I think every man has their own opinion
to be honest in general
all right Maggie The Substitute Teacher
can't wait to see you soon keep it up
Pearl yeah Maggie's coming she's doing
an episode of wife School we're doing
wife school where you know modern women
we learn traditional things okay yeah so
you know you want to not cook clean all
that jazz yeah so she's gonna come help
me cook what are you gonna teach me how
to cook Maggie I'm a chef by the way
you're a chef yeah I love to cook what
do you cook everything like what okay I
can learn everything okay what do you
cook now um spaghetti I mean that's kind
of a bridge what I cook Nigerian food
too like I just learned jollof rice
really yeah I cheat though most of the
time I do it in the rice cooker I know
my sister too it's so easy just like
stars
I've done it the other one really it
takes so long I gotta clean all the pot
I just yes I mean whatever works for you
yeah yeah so you make traditional
Nigerians yeah what's the best thing oh
Legacy I go see soup it's like a it's
actually from My Tribe as well it's very
known in my tribe so you have it with
pounded yam so it's like potato like
mashed potatoes but it's like more yam
what tribe um
is that a big one no no we do have the
Kings and Queens over there oh okay I've
learned so much about Nigeria this year
yeah because we've got so many Nigerians
on the show there must be a lot of
Nigeria yeah
[Music]
and the average family size is like five
kids yes
yeah yeah that's very true do you feel
like it's more diverse here or in
well depends where you go New York is
similar but where I'm from no it's not
very diverse really I live in Chicago
suburbs so it's pretty it's just white
people yeah
yeah
cool we do have culture okay I really
hate people say white people don't have
culture okay and I'm really tired of
this because white people we have the
best Karen's yes and we do and you know
you guys can hate on Karen's all you
want but we do what everyone is thinking
yes everyone wants to complain about the
Neighbors being loud we go complain
everyone wants to get the manager we do
it we do it so as much as everyone's
like oh she's a character you put the
intentions into actions
what everyone's thinking I think Karen's
are very needed for society yes very
needed oh no a 20
and my followers got money
enjoying the content it's refreshing
hearing some people speak common sense
and especially guys when you send the
super chats it's like I have people
insult my followers say that they have
no jobs they're just bums that watch me
that London hate group says this okay I
do have a hate group in London I'm sure
that girl that left is gonna join it
definitely don't worry I have a love
group too you know not like that nothing
weird okay
but you know anyway so when you guys
send supers I can be like no they're not
brokies yes
every time I say something and now
you're asking for a man who's in the top
10 of men
you don't qualify for one
and you're making I mean I don't I don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's
an average guy
what is she doing
I think she's reading the comments oh so
it's kind of like minor here
I want to figure out how to get them on
the screen blessing us to help me I
don't know how to do it
yeah blessing I feel like
um
oh
in order to full fully submit I have to
feel like he's in well then you're gonna
then you're gonna die alone how about
that yeah all right let me just cut to
the chase man uh you can feel like what
you want to but women like you die alone
straight up because you think you're
better than the men that you qualify for
and the only reason honestly ma'am that
I can see a woman like yourself really
thinking you deserve more is because you
earn more because you earn more money
than most people around you in North
Carolina say something that I don't know
it's just like in my head when he says
die alone everyone naturally dies alone
but I feel like what he like meant to
say was like you're gonna die without
being loved the way you want to like
you're not gonna give it to be one
without a family right because when you
think about it the decision to not have
a family it's like even if you choose to
like break up your heart like families
are so different yes when it's like
around the people that love you know
it's just so different with versus like
you know by yourself for sure but no I
think you're women do you are you a big
family person
women usually do die alone though yes we
live longer than men
yeah we usually do
and we date older so it's like a double
win you know my dad told me I think I
said this yesterday he's like you can't
date I had an ex-boyfriend yes very
successful man who's a bit overweight
all right and my dad's like you can't do
that like you gotta take the other guy
even if he's got less money but not fat
and he was just like because you're
gonna have to take care of him and deal
with all his health issues and I was
like
one more go for the reaction oh yeah you
could bring her in
trouble
is she coming oh she's going to get
if your ass worked at the post office
you would not think so highly of your
opportunities
and that's the reality we don't men
don't care about your money
not the kind of man that you want we
it ain't ours and we care about the fact
that you are older and you got kids
and you're average
and your reality of your life has showed
you that
you don't have the kind of meaning that
you want no come on oh no you're good
come on in come on in welcome how was
your date it was cute I guess it was
cute or you were you treated like a
queen not really
would you go on a second date Maybe not
maybe not
all right
you friend zone did they interview you
after about it no we haven't done that
oh okay I think they're going too late
here's your headphones thank you are you
aware of who Kevin Samuels is oh the one
yes yeah have you seen this content you
can scoot him a little bit if it's tight
it's gonna drag me off the chair yeah
that's right I don't know how to okay
well hopefully that works
um oh wait I need to I need to read the
supers
um a lot of people call my followers
broke we don't have no broke
oh no no no no no no Alvin she showed up
at a steakhouse but wants to but wants
Sushi send the asteroid send the
asteroid talking about that girl oh
um Charlie Brown Charlie looks like
we're even the best friends you know how
to make sure love rice Pearl I do major
props unemployed I'm a small business
owner and I have a ft job put some
respect on our names I know they just
say it's a bunch of men just whining I'm
like the amount of one-on-ones I've had
with guys that make over 100k is kind of
crazy so they all need to pipe down
let's put some respect on the jpt gang's
name also guys sign up for my email list
I know I've said this a million times
but I'm pushing it because we are going
to do meetups in every city okay and I
really want to set people up I really
want to help you know facilitate a
community role we're all having fun a
lot of Pals and we're gonna do boxing if
you want to see me box some crazy people
someone
I have to find a good opponent that's in
the ring I want to wow it has to be
someone the girls that have asked me to
box they're like from my London hate
group but they they're not they're not
famous enough
yeah really
yeah I would I would I actually feel
like I'd get along with her but you know
I feel like I could I'm I'm an athlete
you know what I mean I'm an athlete
that's why women lie they're thinking no
she can't kiss
[Music]
a show for dating okay we're so we're
towards the end but I'm gonna just yeah
looking on your door trying to find you
see what we've done in this country this
world is we've told women like yourself
that you can have it all and you got a
prince charming who's six foot
six feet tall six figure income jawline
all this other kind of stuff and I'm
sorry man no
most people get average people
especially average people
you're an average person I mean let's be
real you're not well she's got thoughts
I want to hear your thoughts she's like
oh my God to be called average I feel
like that's like less than being called
ugly really like that's just like so
you're just like because you can be ugly
but with the personality but to be
called like average it's just like
you're just I wonder why that is because
most people are average
doing like
I don't know there's like people who do
like certain stuff and then there's
people who just like live everyday lives
but like they're happy with that like
that's their little bubble so it's just
like cool
what does she do like that I don't know
I haven't seen what she does yeah it's
just like most people have normal jobs
most people do average things you know I
I just don't know I feel like as women
we're all delusional because we all
think we're special delusions sometimes
can work in your favor though I agree I
was delusional to start this thing
and it worked out but I would say most
obviously I've met a lot of delusional
women over the past year and a half I
think if you're delusional and can't
back it up then it's like the bad type
of delusional but if you can walk the
walk and talk the talk then okay I like
the delusion like I remember I used to
tell everyone at school like I would be
out here interviewing big big
celebrities one day my first ever like
red cop interview interviewed rapid
delusional yeah oh shut up you want to
read Brett hold on hold on that's my
life how did how did that happen so I
literally there was this guy on
Instagram and like he used to put
adverts to do like premieres and things
like that and I must message him and I
didn't get that job and then like the
night before he calls me like super I
was like hey do you want to do bullet
train like red carpet I was like I'm
canceling everything like yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes and he kind of told me
like listen we're at the end of the
carpet you're probably not going to be
able to talk to like the big big people
so don't like have your expectations
like I said I'm just happy to be here
and then like yeah Brad Pitt can I see
you got a video I know you got a video
on it do I have a video if that if that
happened Taylor Johnson literally like
the video of me and irritated Johnson
literally got like a mill views on my
Tick Tock well while you find it I'm
gonna read these supers real quick read
these supers hold on one second guys
again email list events sign up keep
modern women accountable accountable
keep hitting people with reality praying
for you to pair up with a good man and
have a large family the center of my
world I'm broke okay well you didn't
have to you didn't have to say that okay
um Chief Keef Pearl we ain't broke I'm
fit 100k with benefit stocks all
together not just not six foot these
haters can put some respect on
just ignore this
um I like to watch Pearl all YouTubers
that have members page to sign up for
their option there's a page next to
their name but for some reason there's
no option next to your YouTube page
I'm gonna screenshot that because I
actually don't
I don't know how to do you got to fix
that big fan thank you again the Super
Chat thanks for showing them we're not
all brokies except apparently except
apparently um the center of my world who
said he is broke so yeah
um okay let's see should I hold out
I don't know if you can see the
reflection I don't know if it's gonna
load but I guess you know the YouTubers
but you can see him then yeah that's so
cool and like he was so like he's so hot
in real life really he's a very very
defensive man would you ask him I was
asking him like what's about the movie
no I think I was asking what his
favorite thing about London is and like
if he would take something from like
what he would take from Japan and put in
yeah that's the direct like producers
and they director
so how old are you I'm 21. 21. so you
are attracted to 40 something year old
men look I mean
the girl on the thing was saying that
young girls don't like older men no like
I can find him physically attractive but
if he wanted to date me I know how to
find that weird I'd be like you're
questionable yeah you should try it you
might you might be living a night you're
like my dad's Asian that's so weird like
if my dad brought him a girl that was my
age I'll be like
um I'd be happy because not now because
he's married but if he wasn't right no I
met my dad oh like I'm like you know I'd
be I'd be like good job dad
girl what you here for
and in Microsoft you got you had a pet
grooming business
been making six figures for the last
three years
okay
oh she looks upset and she is but if I'm
looking at you but if I looked at you
and I took all that off of you all the
eyelashes and all the hair what do you
look like under there oh I mean I look
the same man just no you don't because
if you did you wouldn't have all that
out
I'm sorry no you don't you don't look
the same because if you did you wouldn't
have all that on
so what is your advice for uh all right
I'll tell you my advice man because
you're not listening to me this is why I
always recommend you need to stay
therapy
people think most of us in black
community need therapy but you're not
you're not dealing with reality
I asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me
but it doesn't sound like you're too
proud of him
how's it what kind of student is your
child
does he have any behavioral problems no
he actually got a YouTube channel and
he's trying I don't need that I don't
need no no no but where is it but his
daddy is still if his daddy is alive
does he have a relationship with his
father
then what's your issue with him
um he's not
um business minded like my father and my
uncle and then why did you choose to
make a baby with him before you got
married
oh what are you thinking you think you
you what do you think about this
exchange I can see the point he's trying
to make but at the same time we don't
know the situation a lot of people have
babies out of wedlock depending on their
beliefs you know what I'm saying like
some people don't necessarily believe in
abortion so she might have had the baby
because she didn't want to get rid of it
but as well I don't like when men kind
of put the blame on the woman when it's
a lot of the time like dads are leaving
the household like that's not
necessarily because before we know their
relationship could have been [__] up
like and like it was better it's better
to live and I feel like a separated
happy home than a two-parent household
where it's fighting because that's just
as worse I I think that the outcome of
the family is most of the time 100 the
woman's fault
yeah
I think because you know when you're
ovulating
I I just think it's under it's your
responsibility to make sure that the guy
that you procreate with is a good man
yeah if you don't have good Role Models
around you it's your job to go find some
and get their advice yeah and I think
that if you make a baby with someone
that isn't a good man that's your own
fault and I think it says something
about you that you don't make decisions
well it does take I do feel like people
should take responsibility for
themselves in that respect like that 100
agree because then it's like if you knew
he was a bad guy and you still went
there then it's just like you knew the
outcome but let's like let's begin like
like say like having a baby with Nick
Cannon not to like business but like you
know your child is not gonna get special
special attention and so I was like I
can feel your pain but at the same time
kind of useful is it really yeah it
takes two to make a baby but yeah you
can see the red flags trying to avoid it
but so why don't why do you not like
blaming women when it is our fault
because I think at the same time like
when emotions come into things it can
like blind your logic so some women like
it's like when people stay in abusive
relationships it's like someone who's
never been in that situation can of
course be like why don't you just leave
why don't you just leave it's like
you're so emotionally that's why I think
therapy is good but then I know a lot of
people can afford therapy or don't
actually know
what's going on yeah so it can get a bit
see I I still think if you're an abusive
relationship it's your fault I don't
think you deserve it which is different
like I don't think it's like I don't
think it's not your fault if he hits you
but it's your fault if you stay yeah
because a lot of times those girls will
like go back like keep going back to him
and it's just like yeah that that is the
question and then and then on top of it
you you make a child with him it's the
it's the emotional manipulation or like
sometimes Financial it's literally you
know I think it is
I think it's stupid because I actually
know someone that did that just for the
sake of staying with the guy she had a
whole baby and everyone that really
genuinely cared about her was like
listen leave open your eyes like do the
right thing some people don't want to be
saved but I don't I don't think it's
like like I feel like sometimes we use
these words to take accountability off
of women like emotional manipulation
it's like you're kind of putting it back
on him when it's your choice it is but
like because if you don't if you're not
like emotionally mature then you don't
like yours whose fault is it if you're
not emotionally mature
it's like it's kind of like you're
talking like we're kids We're Not Kids
yeah a tree if you're like I do feel
like a bit like yeah the
self-responsibility part does need to
come into account sometimes and it's
like
if you'll see again if you'll see in the
morning size and you're still it's like
saying this fire is hot yeah it's still
going in there it's like so even though
this is like mean or it sounds mean
right it's hard I should say harsh is a
harsh reality but isn't it better that
she knows the reality so she can make
decisions accordingly reality is always
best I think reality gives people a
better understanding of how they should
maneuver in life and especially like I
know everyone says like sugar shoot your
shot but it's like I know I couldn't go
up to like Justin Bieber
like date me because I'm just like I
don't know like you've never met me I'm
not like I've not been in your Social
Circle so it's like kind of be real or
even like level up so that you're within
those circles I think it's better to
like level yourself up and be able to
like match that high aspect person that
you're trying to get rather than just be
like wait Give Me Everything wait hold
on say that again I'm sorry so I'm
saying like it's better to kind of try
and level how do you level yourself up
in a sense of like social Circle wise
money-wise business-wise like moving up
the ranks so it's not like weird like
where's this woman come from and it's
like you're not do you think men care
about your money
yeah
I don't think they care as much
I don't know I don't know do you think
men care about your Social Circle and
your status so like clout clout chasing
guys do is that typically the men that
women want no so
um so it's like if you're gonna level up
how would you do that for men
I have I have failed what makes you
think about it yeah I don't I because I
don't like them because what do men
really want not these nails
I'll keep ordering why they typically
want Purity youth Purity they don't want
a girl that's banged the whole football
team okay bud I didn't say you did I was
talking about you I have I have not they
they preferably want to grow with under
um 10 bodies they don't want to grow
this up with more than 10 typically
ideal would be under seven from what
I've interviewed guys
um so you're actually you know your
chances of having a happy marriage is
um it depends on how many partners
you've had so if you've only had one
partner you have an 80 chance of being a
happily married in 10 in 10 years if
you've had two it drops down to 50 if
you get over five it gets around 20 well
relationships five sexual partners so if
you've had sex with over Five Guys your
chance of having a happy marriage in 10
years is 20 how did they study that
um they would ask people how many sexual
partners they had and then in 10 years
they would ask if they're happy and
they're still married wow
so it's it's a pretty like clear
correlation the more Partners you've had
the less likely you are to stay barbages
just seems so upsetting nowadays we
don't see anyone like Jaden will we were
like clinging on and then all their
stuff came up and it was like it's
because of women women are the problem
in most marriages
not all but most we leave who who's
whose fault is it the quitter or the
person that stays
oh it's like it's a joint thing it's a
joint right but if me and you make an
agreement right we say hey we're going
to be together for life okay and you
leave and I say whose fault is it I
guess I'll if I'm not abusive if I'm not
abute because that's all the first thing
is like girls would be like oh men are
abusive and cheaters okay let's take
those off the tables
if it's neither of those thing things
and I stay and you quit whose fault is
it
what does someone
so much too because everyone like
because it's like especially like you
know have you heard the thing of like um
like oh what's the thing when it's like
men purposely don't do house chores
because they know the women's gonna do
it do do women purposely fix things
around the house and mow the lawn
because women will always whine about
doing house chores but they don't talk
about men usually fix things around the
house mow the lawn what they don't do
that stuff then they're just like Sons
like grown sons basically you know what
I mean like men if men are grown son
husbands it's the fault of women
because what would you agree with the
statement men will do anything to get
laid yes
so if women are accepting grown son's
son husbands whose fault is that yeah it
makes it kind of peak for the rest of us
because then it's like if you have a
certain standard then you're high
maintenance but it's like no this is
just but I feel like also
um as much as the woman you know because
what if the woman tries to change the
son husbands and you know tries to you
know better them but then they still
have a choice uh yeah like why are you
trying to change Madness that usually
productive now you know that you know
the girls are like I can change
[Laughter]
typically a good strategy to get you
make a good man guy that doesn't do much
is it a good strategy to try to change
him no but maybe like highlighting a few
things would give them a
viewpoint on what to work on
maybe you can't just go around being a
dick okay do you do you have women
friends that are lazy that are just bums
you know any did they ever magically one
day not become a bum no have they always
have they gotten better or worse over
time
are the same I don't have to be mobile I
used to be a bum you used to be a mom I
used to be a complete bomb and I used to
clean and I used to do anything but as
weird as it may sound I had like a
spiritual awakening and that opened my
eye to more things and was it because of
someone else or because of you because
of me so is it smart to go after guys
that are bums no I'm gonna try to make
that it's just a long day for you guys
oh my gosh yeah that's why I think the
whole state of society is women's fault
yeah
um
yeah yeah I think yeah I think
everything's women's fault you're a
woman yeah yeah she's like yeah but I'm
smart
I I think um we can look at things as at
a society level and not necessarily an
individual level right I'm not saying
well your relationships and your lives
are your own fault personally just like
mine mine as well right but as a society
again men will do anything to get laid
yeah it's kind of scary if they act a
certain way it's the fault of women and
I've also interviewed men they they act
like bad guys because we prefer them
when we're younger yeah and so whose
fault is it if the men act bad if we're
picking the bad men it's a tea I feel
like it's a two-sided thing because like
women are feeding and into men's sing by
the men feed into women so it's just
like this
who started it
who is in control of sex men or women
women women a thousand percent yes but
so so so who started it
well sometimes but I would say sometimes
like the way men come towards women it
can be like a lot of women would just be
like Oh I'm just gonna do it
yeah yeah because a lot of women don't
even half the time so so whose choice is
that
assuming there's no assault right
assuming there's none of that whose
fault
there's a guy at Tesco down the street
it could just be my you know like you
know what with like men I feel like we
already know how they would react
did you get it we already know their
intentions like the way they would talk
to us what what they would do for us so
for us to react to certain way it's it's
really and truly like up to us to
spread them cheeks or not but now that
women have a like standards like they
even have you seen all the videos on
Tick Tock like as soon as you start to
understand for yourself the amount of
men is like I'll tell you oh I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why it's because
you're no longer as valuable as you were
before
in what sense so again what amend value
Purity youth looks main main three
things roughly I mean there's
rough overview right like what what did
every King have
hot young virgins
you know like and so so what girls will
do is they'll have sex with all the bad
guys they'll have sex with like 10 15
bad guys whatever it is and then they'll
ask for the same price as they demanded
at when they were 10 years younger in a
virgin
and now they have less options because
the guys don't want to pay that much
you're a used car and you oh no you've
got but don't you think you should just
like be able to have fun in your younger
years
um it depends what outcomes you want
like if you're just like exploring no
I'm saying like what like do you want to
be married with kids or do you want to
be by yourself or do you want to be with
a woman
so if you want to be married with kids
is it is it good to have a lot of exes
that you've slept with is that good for
a marriage I mean what about the like to
contradict that a little bit it's like
when men be like oh I want a free girl
but then you can't be a freak without
having slept because then if you're pure
then your might be classed as like
boring what do they want the freak girl
for
do men typically wife freak girls
typically
no no not really
any so so they do want the it's it's not
sad because it's based on choices
there's no problem if you want to Market
yourself yeah if you want to Market
yourself as the freak girl and that's
the type of men you want to attract
that's fine you'll probably get access
to higher value men than the normal girl
if that's your mating strategy you want
to just give it up and see if you can
get one of them to stay that's a
strategy okay try it but do you think
do you think you can blame everyone if
she doesn't like know any better
um I it's not about blame it's about
outcomes you know what I mean it's like
you could say I was young but that
doesn't take away the fact that you
slept with 20 dudes yeah you know you
could we could have some empathy and
understanding but it doesn't change the
outcome of the situation which is men
are going to look at you different if
you've done certain things and they find
out now most girls will lie and some
girls get away with it but you can't lie
to yourself like girls talk too much
they'll slip up about it
I mean five men yeah I think girls are
aware of that but it's like the same way
of like a guy has slept with burgers and
whatever what if a woman like I was like
I want my future husband to only upset
with three women that's going to be like
do you think do you think that's common
no do you think it's common for women to
want that from Men
maybe do you think that women are that
want to sleep with say Drake or worried
about his body count no no they don't
want to do things like anything of men
um that if they were gonna date Amber
Rose they would be worried about her
past no but these are publicly
you don't think
a man that's like making six figures
he's got his own business would be
worried about Amber Rose's reputation
dating her
no probably not but she's based the
whole brand around sex
you think there's other [__] like [__]
on her foot yeah I'm saying you don't
think there's things like you don't
think he would have any qualms about
having her as a mother of his kids
that would be tough for a wife
maybe but she has kids which is which is
that's that's the strategy the Horus
kind of use is they get they get the kid
off of the guy that makes a lot of money
and they don't want to be a wife they
just want to be side chick that's fine I
mean do that fine we've had side chicks
for all of history I feel like that's
why she goes for Like Rappers and yeah
she's trying to get the goodies she even
said it herself yeah she did I think I
know because I just the side chick life
I didn't I would I would just always
like want more for yourself type Vibe
like it's just kind of I mean if that's
what you want to do but you can you can
want more but can you get it and at this
point is she gonna get a guy that's
making good money and is successful that
wants to take her seriously that does
all the low maybe as a side chick right
she's not going to be the main I have a
question yeah so if a woman that has
this like history of like crazy sex
whatever experiences and now she's like
you know what I want to change I want
like a real guy I'm ready to be this
woman that he wants me to be what do you
think is the like
do I think it's possible I think it's
possible that it's not probable
and it depends when did she do it
because the more time you like were you
doing that for five years it's gonna
take you probably five years to turn it
off at least well we're doing it for 10
if if I ate dessert every day for 10
years it wouldn't be hard to quit very
yeah and it's the same thing with that
so guys kind of look at okay how long
did you do it for when did you do it and
how bad was it oh well it was an
acceptable age to stop kind of going out
I mean I wouldn't recommend like if you
want to be a wife if that's the outcome
I wouldn't recommend doing it at all but
you know this youngest you can't stop
especially that people who go to
university where it's like you have more
access and like there's no parental
that's when a lot of people do their
experimenting and that's when they say
like I went through my host phase that's
so true you know what I'm saying that's
what a lot of people have their like
college experience where I was like I
when you've just lost it I feel like I
feel like because when I just lost my
like sorry if I'm if it's sensitive but
when I just lost my virginity it I just
went
crazy like I've never felt this feeling
before and I want to feel it again
because it feels
you couldn't keep doing it with the same
guy
um you know what I tried to but then
this guy like he obviously I found out
that he was like playing and he just
wanted me for the uh yeah yeah so I was
like you know what I don't want it well
the the issue is you're you're gonna
you're gonna be so if you're sleeping
around casually usually girls sleep out
of their league yeah so you don't really
know what your league is until you look
at the guys that are willing to date you
yeah because you can guys will sleep
with anything right I mean have you ever
been cheated on and you look at the girl
he cheated on you I mean don't be a
person but but you you've heard that
right these guys cheat with like I can't
believe her yeah yeah yeah I feel like
that's even worse because it's like
she's not even lame I would have
understood if she was language
yeah because it's if you're a girl
that's a five six seven right and you're
sleeping with an eight nine or ten
you're gonna get the guy that you
actually date and you're gonna miss the
guy from before and I'm sure you've seen
that with maybe a friend or something
where they're dating one guy but they
miss the old one and that's the problem
you get when you've had more and more
Partners is like how how is the guy
that's going to take you seriously gonna
compare well she didn't you like what
about like the phrase try before you buy
like if you even buy like a product
you'll look up reviews see how it looks
so much see because especially as a
woman you need to kind of know what you
like I guess because I know I didn't say
like wait till you're married but I you
know
um I think women kind of act dumb like
they can't tell who's taking them
seriously and who's not and when you
really ask questions like did he take
you on a date did he do this did he do
that and you really peel back delay
I don't know sometimes sometimes in life
you're gonna take L's right and there's
gonna be guys that bamboozle you but the
majority of guys it's pretty easy to
tell if you and most guys will tell you
if you ask them it's true I mean that's
an inward thing though because you've
got a kind of I think certain women are
afraid of being alone and that's why
they kind of are like serial debated
like serial datas and they can't like be
by themselves that's why I do think it's
good for women to be single for like at
least a year so you understand like the
kind of piece it gives you because
otherwise all you know is relationships
of course you're going to stay in a bad
relationship and especially now that
people want romance so badly do you
think a man that's looking for a wife
wants a girl that's at peace being alone
I think yeah because he knows that she's
like a good she doesn't need to be out
there all the time like she can be her
own person
but they always say but like don't they
say like you're [__] you'll find your
perfect guy when you least expect it so
if you're minding your business and you
can't and you're not like what is
marriage
I don't know I'm young I can't so two
two plus two it's there's some phrase
it's like too flush become one so it's
like two become one right and so if a
guy's looking for a wife why would he
want a girl that's okay being alone when
he wants to be with her forever
because she can you can you can be with
somebody but also being able to have
peace and not be like dependent like oh
you're my husband I need to do
everything with you though this is like
this is why this is why like women have
no idea what men want they want a girl
that's clingy the only time the guys
don't like girls that are clingy that
they don't like but think about the last
guy that's really chased you or been
into you do you think he would have
cared if you were clingy no no he would
have liked it because I'm literally
experiencing him like saying right now
so I'm like but you guys everything's
actually true everything everything
you're saying is from like a feminine
point of view because we don't like men
that are clingy
so you put up like you made you think
that's what men want that's not true
we'll never know because we're not meds
I could never say it's like I could ask
men I've asked my guy I have a lot of
like really great guy friends and I've
kind of awesome like am I intimidating
like why do you guys not want to date me
and it's like I don't know it's just
weird I'm just I would rather be at
peace than just be in my face and just
be like just like oh this is a lot what
are the what do the guys say when you
say am I intimidating what are they say
they say that I can come off
intimidating due to my job and like
like I've had people think that I've
been a [__] before just because I'm
confident I'm kind of like quite direct
because usually like I will flirt with
guys or if they flirt with me because I
haven't been like taken out in a long
time I don't I can't read the signals
probably so I think they're just being
friendly back and then it's like oh you
played that guy I'm like what I'm just
being nice like and so I think what
they've said is I need to learn to like
be a bit more
so I'll miss it so to speak so I'm I'm
it's true I'm trying but I think it's I
I think once you've been hurt so many
times it's hard to submit because a lot
of women submit and get hurt so it's
like what's the point of doing that if
this outcome is going to be the same who
are who are they submitting to who are
they picking to submit to
food for you guys
yeah and then whose fault is that yeah I
guess but what about like when you meet
a guy and he he's so nice at the start
you think like oh my God could this be
the one and then you submit and then
he's an answer is that typical yeah you
think I mean I haven't you think men
switch up completely well not completely
but like enough because once questions
so I'm in a really good it's okay I
think some of them are good because like
you said they'll do anything and say
anything and if you're not experienced
enough in the dating world like you're
just coming into so say you're like 16
as some older guys like yeah I'll take
you out I'll buy you flowers and you're
thinking oh my gosh
and then he's just an [__] she's like
what happened and I feel like at that
age at 16 we still thinking your brain
hasn't even the question is how long did
you wait to sleep with him
and not not you but like like in general
right because it's like if you're
sleeping with them right away
what does that tell you yeah
because women I feel like women
sometimes use sex to kind of keep the
mind because they know that's what men
want so it's not necessarily that you
would like to but because you like him
so much or like I'll give you whatever
this is what I can do to to make him
stay and that's a natural submission
that's yeah it's kind of upsetting that
you said what's your job again you're an
influencer
I'm a black presenter and I do content
for me and other brands yeah um I think
marketing yourself on the internet where
you're flirting with other guys is gonna
I don't flip no that's what you that's
what you said before you said when
you're doing interviews you're like
flirting with guys oh no not in my
interviews oh my God oh my God okay oh
my God no I'm like oh my God okay okay
yeah no I'm just like if I'm at an
industry event oh my gosh oh okay okay
um man and I'll say this is someone with
a big following it doesn't help really
no I don't think it helped at all it's
actually kind of a negative like men
prefer girls that aren't low-key no I I
get that and that's the thing that's
that's why I've struggled a lot as well
and but it's hard because it's like you
can try and someone within the industry
but then it's like sometimes it can be a
competition thing or like they want
someone who's at home but then if you're
marrying someone who let's just says
like an accountant like a really good
working like a bang and had a really
cool job but you're gonna be like flying
because I fly out places and he's at
home and I'm thinking oh it's kind of
peak on him what kind of guy do you want
I don't know anymore I haven't met like
do you know you're 21. I'm 21. I've not
been out there long enough and I've been
single for a really long time but it's
like
just someone who's can show me things
that I can't show myself I would say and
someone who can like take control and
even if I am working can still like have
my back and share me on and not be
jealous of it
okay like oh so so not jealous please
has your back do you want to work do you
want to stay home what do you want to do
I want to work as long as I can to like
I mean I want to work to a point where
I've made my money and I'm known enough
in an industry that I can still do jobs
here and there but then be able to just
like just chill like when I hit like
about like 30 just when you'll be able
to chill so like work work work chill
out okay
um when do you want to have kids
not until I'm like late late late 20s
but like days okay so 30s when does when
does geriatric pregnancy start I don't
know what
that is when when does it when does it
become more increasingly high risk to
have a child
that's like a phase
women be pumping out babies at 40 like
you know what they don't show you the
the women that didn't pop out babies at
40 and that tried
it's not you don't have I mean you're 21
so you have time yeah but geriatric
pregnancy starts at 35 and half your
eggs are gone by 30. wow so you know
you know people can have kids and do the
career thing later it's true but with my
line of work I would say I can't
necessarily like it's like if you're a
model it's like you only have when
you're young yeah yeah you can do it for
a sec even like athletes you have to do
it in your kind of prime so that
afterwards you're like good enough which
is which is fine but you know it's just
a trade-off because it's going to be
unattractive to the men you want well to
have a kid afterwards no to well to be
older a girl that's in the industry
that's been around industry men for 10
years like so let's say you get married
at 30 right you're gonna have been
around these high value men for 10 years
right because you're around all the
celebrities you'll probably have hooked
up with a couple by then
just I mean come on you're gonna you're
gonna be around them for 10 years
nothing you're not gonna go on a date
nothing so you're gonna hit 30 right
you're gonna have been around these men
for 10 years and
you know you have a whole big social
media following it's like that's going
to be unattractive too and if you make a
lot of money the guys you want it's
going to be a small percentage because
you're going to want someone that makes
more money than you yeah but I think you
should be allowed to date someone within
that realm you shouldn't be looking at
no I I think you're allowed to but I
just think what what percent of guys do
you think make six figures I know it's
not a lot but you don't have to make six
figures to be comfortable
how much do you need to be comfortable
depends where you live okay how much
where do you want to live like between
here and like I would say
I love New York in like Miami okay so in
a big city how much do you need to be
comfortable
six figures no drinks
like kids with kids oh with kids oh how
much money do you need
anything combined or individually
um how much combined combined I would
say like if you're both on a good salary
of at least like
Maybe
like at least like 50k enough okay so
100K total is a household yeah I guess
and if you aren't gonna work you'd have
to make what
I don't know I don't know how much
things cost that's why I'm like no it's
okay that's okay I mean even if we
brought it down to 80 or 70. yeah and
I'm not I'm not faulting you for
anything yeah but I'm just telling you
that the older you are you're gonna be
uglier
black don't crack so I don't agree with
that because I'm I'm basically like a
lot of women that I know who are like of
the same it doesn't mean you'll probably
look better than say white women at 30
right but
you're still gonna be uglier than you
are now I'll say uglia I'll say more
mature season but I'm telling you how
men see it is less attractive but then
let's attract so like like half of them
are bold then like I'll tell you I'll
tell you that's not true that's not true
so man if you look at dating app swipes
women half of um by the time when you
start at 18 to when you're 30 your
swipes go down by 50
where men they just go up
because women we look at other things
like their job if they're funny if all
this stuff and they get funnier over
time they get the younger women us will
still date the 40 or at least look at
the 45 year old where the it's not the
same for men We're Men around our age at
like 30 35 they start dating younger and
younger that's just weird though I feel
like men who date younger
can't don't have the capability of
dating women their own age why why would
they date someone their own age when
they could date younger so if not even
with women if men like girls with low
body counts if they like young
attractive women that can bear that can
have kids for them why would they want
to date someone their own age because
it's like what do you have in common
with like if a 30 year old came to me as
like what do we have do you think men
care that much about what they have in
common with a girl
at some point in their life yes because
you see a lot of men who date these
pretty modern women it gets to a point
where they're like oh yeah she's pretty
but what else is she bring in like can
we have a conversation do you think that
rich men that have the most options
don't date model of women they model
women but I do I think deep down inside
everyone wants someone they can actually
like talk to you and I think like they
realize that's why a lot of them eating
men do you think men value talking to
their women
I think if you're an intelligent man
then yes do you think that men want to
talk all the time not all the time but
at least if you're out to dinner if I'm
just there like oh my God hey guys like
just on my phone what's more important
to men looks or talking
intellectual man talking
foreign
you think okay so you think that Jeff
Bezos do you think he's an intellectual
man yes do you think that Leonardo
DiCaprio is an intellectual man yeah
okay I think that Drake's do you think
Drake's an intellectual man yeah I know
okay two out of the three of them date
like 22 year olds 25 year olds very true
they do they all date younger but the
cereal date is they can't stay in a
relationship and that just goes to
preview a point where you are unable to
sustain something because you're dating
women who you are just getting for four
licks that's that's nothing that's just
do you think they want to stand what
incentive do men have to stay in
relationships to have a family
good mother that you know is like these
are my children these are like your
these are parts of you like why would
you not want someone great to raise your
kids so it's interesting I used to have
that thought right and I never
understood why men would want to be
alone okay I used to think that and what
I realized is so if if you let's say you
became a millionaire okay and you
decided to have a child with with a guy
okay and if that guy who let's say he
changed his mind all the time every day
he was in out I don't know like just a
bunch of different whatever and he had
the power to leave at any point
90 chance he he takes the kid with him
and he's gonna take 50 to 80 percent of
all the money you made
would you sign up for that no prenup
so prenups aren't legally binding here
and what they're not legally binding
here no
no that's crazy well I'm a U.S citizen
so I'll get married in America so so
prenups in the US it depends on the
state
but the 50 50 the kids so you can
protect your assets more in a prenup but
when it comes to children
and child support
an alimony so men don't have a lot of
incentive so you're an American says
where are you from yeah like all my
families well like my dad's from New
York and all my family live in Florida
I'm from Chicago but but yeah there's
just not as much incentive nowadays
I that's because I didn't think there's
been a lot of people who have had happy
marriages like you don't really look
around and see that so why which and
even as a woman I see a lot of the time
women getting cheated on by Mistresses
and being a mistress seems more fun than
being a wife nowadays because they
they'd be out and proud about it but
boys more men or women
men
I feel like women can lie more of like
men is it different I think it's a
different type of lying than they're
just just lying
men or women
I'm saying like I'm a woman
you think women lie more who who wears
more makeup fake hair extensions fake
lashes I mean the trans now listen but
women do that but it's do you think
that's lying about your appearance okay
I 100 get your point and I've like
always tried to advocate for girls being
natural like I'm pretty I would say well
semi-natural I know my hair's blonde and
stuff but yeah I'd say I get a test
you're not wearing a tunnel yeah no no I
went very very minimal makeup but that's
I have like why'd you do the hair like
blonde
[Music]
I'm like not natural looking stuff oh
yeah but I wore my hair out natural for
I've only done this for two years my
husband natural
um you should bring it back the whole
recipe yeah but he's like some men like
men like natural I know but they like
that but they but then I kind of fit
into their category of being like a
fair-skinned curly-headed woman so
they're not really liking me for my
personality and that's one of the
reasons why I cut it because when I used
to wear my hair out guys used to treat
me like a lot differently and something
would grab on my hair and that's not
that's not nice and like people they
would just grab out your hair in public
no like when I would be in like certain
events like in the club or something
like when I was like young they would
literally if they want to chat they
would call me Mama everything can how
rude like don't do that so a random guy
would come like on a regular basis they
would just grab your hair yeah I've had
multiple men How would how would that
happen I would be walking past and it's
literally like a they would just grab it
yeah that's so weird I've never seen
that's what I'm saying but like people
want to believe but this happened that
it's just like it's made me feel
uncomfortable or people like fetishizing
you do you do you want a boyfriend
I would like a boyfriend but I don't
need no yeah but what would you what
would be ideal to you being with someone
you respect and admire being by yourself
I think if I'm happy with that person
then yeah okay with someone so why would
you not want to dress in a way that
would attract someone that you respect
and admire but I get people are
attracted to me more with my hair like
this because not a lot of people have
this hairstyle like hardly anyone has do
you think men or women are more
attracted to you with your hair like
that I've had a lot of men be like your
hair is really cool because they're
interested they're intrigued but it
brings them it's a conversation stuff
like bro you're here like even when I
was walking here some guy stopped in the
spot was like yeah your hair sick breath
it's literally do you think they're
typically the men you want
when I go no no what I will say is when
I'm like because one time I went to a
private membership club and I've had
mine approach me because I don't look
like the typical girls so why aren't you
with them
if they're the men you want right
because I haven't been with it I don't
usually like I'm just focused on like me
do me right now I'm not like if they
want to take me out cool but I'm just
like it's not that why would you not put
time into the outcome that you would
prefer
because at the end of the day if a
relationship is not going to last longer
than my career right now so I don't want
to like I've put time and energy into
relationship about a marriage no in a
marriage but I want to be celebrated by
your husband I could you know you could
meet your husband that could last 50
years that's longer than any career but
let's be serious who's who's doing that
now it's very unlikely it's based on
what
though like just looking at your parents
no I mean like what what what are the
outcomes of your relationships based on
who determines the outcomes of your
relationship like yeah yourself and that
yeah it's like an equal party you know
what percent chance are you do you have
a college degree uh University yeah did
you no are you in it or no no okay what
percent chance do you think you have of
being left if you got married left yeah
like he would leave he would divorce you
I have no idea 20
women leave 80 of the time roughly
roughly it does that not say something
about how men are in marriage is there I
think it says something about women
we're quitters I don't think what quit
is like at what point is it enough
because it's like would you like why
keep yourself in a bad situation that's
just like excruciate like it's like
having a bad friend like if your friend
is just like a complete also it's not
giving you people accept more [__] from
their friends with their name for years
than their like boyfriend you know do
you know what I can think of a really
good reason children
okay kids yeah because okay when kids
are involved it's a bit different
assuming it's not abuse or assuming it's
not abuse or cheating right is there
what what good reason would there be to
leave well you're not you're not
contributing anything to the woman's
life like you're just there if what if
he has a job right most most guys are
working somewhere he's contributing in
the second income so then you're like
great roommates but it's like okay you
can have a roommate what about
protection
from what
at the crackheads down the street it's
like I've delivered this to crackers my
whole life I haven't had a man come to
fed me for what it's like this whole
thing about like protection I'm like
what like but I can hear it in your
voice you really don't see any value
like it doesn't seem like you you see
the value of like just having a man
around I don't think no Direction
leadership
um but in certain areas I think men can
teach you certain things and it's nice
but again because I'm young I haven't
experienced every man in this world so I
can't like say for sure but it's just if
you're just wasting time I don't see why
stay in a bathroom situation are your
parents still together no no who did you
who did you stay with your mom or your
dad well yeah my mom calls my dad's in
the states in this oh okay when did they
get divorced they weren't married oh
they were never married yeah that says
something
no because I'm just it's just a thing of
like but I've seen their relationship
and that's why I have a certain Outlook
Outlook on how things are and I'm just
like
do you think your childhood would have
been easier if they were together 100
and I tell them all the time I'm like
you guys every time they fight because
they still fight to this day I'm like
guys you're grown adult like let's be so
serious now Mom you could have done this
because I even like I agree with you
there's certain things that women do and
like sometimes you know they do play
victim and I'm like you need to say
responsibility you did this thing wrong
that is why Dad reacted in this way Dad
you did this that's why Mom acted like
why like there's a lot of issues that
can be solved in marriages but one
person when it's like the stubbornness
and so it's just like do you even want
to be happy he's like it's so
interesting because it's like you see
the value that you would have had if you
had both parents in the house about
happy Parents there's no that I would
have hated to be in a household where
the way my mom and dash out on the phone
if that was in real life
bruh that would have been the hell most
people like who I think like who have
parents who have done divorce it is
better separated than just fighting in
the household do you think it's a better
plan to just figure out how to get along
you think that's a choice if you can try
but if you've tried multiple times and
again you're not seeing a result then
how much then you're not you're not
choosing to have the
the piece that you want because how are
you trying if
if it's not working
do you get it like if you if both of you
genuinely want peace and you're trying
it should work
like okay if me and you were living
together right and we were arguing every
day it's a choice to argue back yeah
someone can't argue if you're not if
you're saying like responding you know
what sweetie you're right like you know
it's like like sometimes I feel like if
people just got married and just stayed
married
thick and thin other than divorce
adultery and what's the third addiction
that's it you don't think like I feel
like people wouldn't have as bad of
fights because they would know there's
no getting out of this I mean that's
what marriage should be it's supposed to
be but unfortunately marriage has been
misconstrued in the new age and it's
like do we even know what proper
marriage is supposed to look like
anymore I don't think and I feel like
self-awareness is really important
because if you're not aware of how you
could react if someone says something if
you like then things would be so much
easier like if you know that you can
control yourself in certain situations
with your partner or your husband being
in the room it would be so much easier
do you think it's important to have
examples of married couples you can look
up to 100 every all the Romantic guys
I've met who are my friends their
parents are married and I'm like when I
hear them talk about their parents like
why don't you date them the Romantic
guys that are your friends was that
because they're my friends that's I'm
not I'm physically attracted to them and
it's it's annoying because I'm like
you're not physically attracted to them
no because I'm like I love you so much
as a person but like I just can't I
wouldn't be able to not be there with
you that makes you feel like you're the
one yeah but it's like your friends like
having fun like that is great because
like you know your friends will always
be there for you and I value like if you
have great friends I think
well be there that's good just wait the
guys
wait till they get a girlfriend
poof
but they genuinely love
yeah I mean when it's like your age and
you're in school yeah men and women can
be friends a bit but it's like honestly
when people start getting into serious
relationships that the guys are gonna go
away they're not really your friends I
mean call them right now ask him to
sleep with you see what they're saying
yeah they will definitely say hello
do it do it I could not call that one of
them because you know they'd say what no
would they say yes or no I it depends
which one
no because you know this one's kind of
how many guy friends do you have
um
a few few two five more well it depends
because like friend friend or like
Industries like
let's say like four or five four okay
let's let's take five out of the five
how many do you think would sleep with
you undoubtedly
one one
can you call one of the four now and ask
that would be so awkward come on you can
it's on stream so you can you can send
it to them after and just say that I
said to do it you could send it to them
after and you know you know it'll be
cool like you could show them this you
big YouTuber bullied me into doing it
I'm so just saying just say hey can I
text them or do I have this because
they're probably
see if they want to like do something
today see if they want to do something
yeah
gosh
that's crazy sorry what do you think
a couple years
wait what should I even text them
um say guys put in the chat what she
should text them yeah
um same
you should call him
call him and say
where do you live do you live by
yourself no I live with my mom your mom
a flag it looks so hard I'm moving out
there because you should say you should
say your mom's not home
I'm a little tipsy do you wanna have
some fun
before we'd be like what and then
they're gonna think you're kidding and
you have to be like no no I'm serious he
like did us or why haven't we ever dated
something like that okay
put on speaker phone speaker
Jesus Christ I don't even know hiccup
s
[Music]
hey Adrian
um hey
um I'm basically like gonna be home
alone later did you want to come over
I mean
but I actually grew up now
really
tomorrow are you busy tomorrow
yes
but like link up link up
no like like back in the day
why why
is it because we're friends
it's because we're friends
and you do
but you don't want to do anything with
me
oh you do uh how how am I going to be
anything
like I want to
but I want to
yeah
okay all right thank you
okay
oh okay
[Music]
okay I appreciate you
all right well go enjoy your evening
all right bye
bye see I told you that's the first one
we've ever had my friends are good I
have good guy for people to believe me
yeah when you're good I walked in at the
right time
are they caught with a cup can't believe
it or that what a man declines
did he know you were coming on or no no
no no no okay I want to see I've been
thinking let's go cause otherwise he
would have been like oh how he curved
her so hard yeah you can send her you
can send him the stream if you want
curves no I'm happy that makes you
believe because I don't have any friends
I keep to myself yes really no it's good
to have friends that you know are like
your friends
actually that would you like to look at
other
my gosh my dad I think I was supposed to
experience
Chicago
[Music]
let's finish let's finish the the video
yes and then and then we're gonna close
out the Stream
exactly and that cost see that dumb [__]
let me stop you right here that young
and dumb [__] you black women throw out
as if it's supposed to get
listen and listen well women young and
dumb is not a get out of jail free card
it doesn't go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to 13 year olds I hit up
no no I agree with that I was having
this conversation with my mom the other
day I was like you should 100 tell
someone if they have kids because if you
didn't sign up to be a parent that's a
massive response if I was a man and I
was doing this as a woman you know as a
woman I have definitely got like I've
been on a date and they tell me they've
got a kid
nice to meet you seemed lovely but I got
it it's kind of sad because I do feel
sorry for like single mothers and single
fathers but it's just like we didn't
sign up for that if if someone is
willing to play that role then 100 but a
lot of people unless they really really
love you and your kid because imagine
your kid's like an [__]
respect but no but respectively because
then you're now having to take
disrespect from a kid and you can't even
yours say anything back because it will
offend the mother or the father and it's
like it's a really weird how do you
parent when there's another parent
exactly because I'm like you're not mad
I just paid up to my mom's birthday
you're not my dad shut up like and I you
know there's a man getting told by like
a 13 year old just like yeah crazy with
custody if a guy typically a guy sees
this kid what six days a month if the
woman's dating someone that man will
have more influence on the kid than the
actual Dad yeah and that's I do I do
feel sorry for fathers because that's
like saying how kind of way that I grew
up like I didn't really see my dad a lot
and is it is really upsetting but
unfortunately I don't think the system
really works in a lot of Dad's favors
and I don't think if you're if the
father isn't a complete just like
deadbeat I think
everyone needs to a father in their life
regardless male or female whatever
everyone needs their dad if they're safe
type of vibe because it's just it's not
nice was your dad
um did he try to get custody of you
um yeah and he wasn't able to uh no
because as well because of like the
country thing like being in the UK and
him being in the US so it's like it's
all yeah
it was like a whole thing but we're cool
now we talk all the time now I'm going
literally going to Australia like it's
we worked it out but I do say like I
wish we did grow up as a fan book guys I
forgot to put this forward I'm gonna go
back just re-watch this so they can see
I'm sorry guys black women throw out and
see if he's supposed to give
listen and listen well women young and
dumb is not a get out of jail free card
it doesn't go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to 13 year olds
what would be better is if you honestly
sat down and ask yourself what value can
I bring to a man and I know that what I
can well
all right what can what value what what
is it
but is it blunt yeah I can help him with
this business I'm very busy mana on the
um end of Health what'd you say don't
you think that's what she like needs to
hear because even if she did have that
therapy session what if he spoke the
exact same way
did you get it because that's what she
came on for because if her outcome I
want to be married that's what she said
right you weren't here but earlier in
the call if that was the outcome she
wanted isn't it better to know where you
stand so you can pick the guys that will
want you
yeah but it's just upset because a lot
of the time what men like to say and
kind of sometimes like women yourselves
is like you have to be a housewife to
get a husband and a lot of women
nowadays don't want to be Housewives and
I don't think you necessarily should
have to be a housewife to get a husband
again I think it should be equal parts
and some people should do this like if
if you don't cook maybe you can do this
if you don't do this I can do like
compromise that compromise can make and
break I don't I don't think you need to
be a housewife to get a husband I think
it depends on the outcomes you want in
terms of like I think maybe I think the
best if you want the most children with
the man with the most amount of money
having housewife skills will get you
that outcome
some women don't want that life's about
choices and trade-offs yeah if you're
trying to play that game then 100 yeah
you're trying to blame on me then men
want to feel like they're like taking
like the motherly and what do you get
that from having housewife skills
working with kids like that's what women
also want that from men and sometimes
they don't want mothers not mothers but
we want someone like I would love if
mine cooks for me I'd be like oh my
because I work a lot like I've worked
more than like a lot of the guys I've
dated like I'm coming home would you
prefer cook a home-cooked meal from him
or him taking you out to dinner to a
nice restaurant in London
I think
um because the restaurants are really
cute but then like if you've cooked it's
like
it's okay it's okay I would say in
general though would you agree most
women want the restaurants yeah to go
out so so it's not as valued for the
same things where a guy doesn't want to
be taken out to dinner by a girl it's
like we're just not the same I know it
doesn't it's so hard because we're just
like we were different just the beings
of like male and female because you want
with completely different beings trying
to like coexist is it's crazy so we're
not equal no I don't think we've ever
been equal but when you're saying like
you're a partner you do yeah but like
that's why I say compromise because like
I can't necessarily cook but I would try
and learn to cook but it's like okay but
I can contribute elsewhere what percent
of women do you really think can cook
meals from scratch I don't think as many
nowadays because and as well but I think
that's all the thing where back in the
day you were taught in school yeah and
you did like food Tech once like I only
did again I'm 21 so I'm of like just
finished school and stuff it's like we
only did cooking lessons for about two
three years and I was actually really
good at it I used to be able to cook it
but then after that it's nothing so
wouldn't wouldn't you say that men are
willing to compromise because most women
can't cook but compromise them what what
are they then giving us
us I mean I would say most men are
pretty handy if I need anything fixed
around here I can go to any guy here and
just be like can you fix this and
they'll figure it out and say most men
are handy
um not that they can like build a house
or anything I don't need a house right
now
um I would say protection I really
appreciate having a guy around because I
feel safer I would also say that men
um typically make more than women so
they usually bring in more money than
women because the average income is
around like 45 for men 35 for women
in the U.S I don't want to hear it it's
whatever the equivalent of that roughly
um so you already have money you have
protection you have
fixing things and I also would say
leadership if you appreciate men and
their ability to make decisions from a
more logical point of view I would say
those are all things that most men bring
to the table
where I don't think most women are
nurturing which is something we're
supposed to be do you think so I think
we all but I think you get you nudge it
to a point where again you get a hurt
and say that because I think I think a
lot of women want to be feminine but
cannot be feminine without yeah I do
think they start off nurturing you're
right but I don't I think that again
since the majority of women have been
hurt before and are not virgins and are
not waiting for marriage and have
typically had a [__] past they come in
jaded and not as nurturing because you
kind of make for the men in the future
pay for what you did in the past yeah
and I think there's maybe one guy that
got the feminine version of you or
whoever it was and there's 10 guys that
didn't yeah but yeah that's the and
that's the end with thing that like yeah
because even guys would be like get
heartbroken because no one let's be
certain like no one when they're young
goes into a relationship thinking I'm
gonna be a [__] girl I'm gonna be a [__]
boy everyone wants that like cute high
school like love is just like really
really nice it's not honeymoon
I think that's what everyone wants but
everyone's so scared of hurting each
other that it's just like no one's
really really winning and so it's just
like how do we do you think women are
afraid of hurting men when half of women
have admitted to going on dates for food
that's crazy that's it that's that I
think that is really mean I don't really
like women who do that because it's like
you then can't complain when they say
this when we're feeding in but you would
agree that women they're not afraid of
hurting men because certain women half
at least okay yeah okay wait let's let
me
um
I plant
um into planting my own garden so I can
definitely plan um into
um improving my Elegance with
um
just self-improvement and working on you
see you're gonna start to notice this
women always say what they bring to the
tables what they want from men so she
wants a man that's into self-improvement
so she says self-improvement so
oftentimes when you hear women describe
what they want it's really what they
want
elephants 35 years old at 35 years old
here's what you've told me
I can help him with his business the
respect man
um and I mean no disrespect but 20 to 30
percent of people own businesses what
about the 70 to 80 percent of men who
don't own them that means that doesn't
matter
that means nothing to the average man
then the next thing you said I can plant
man that means nothing to most people
because we go to grocery stores
then you say self-improvement
I gave you a shot it's saying what you
have to offer to men and you said
nothing that we value
what do you buy what do you book a
session book a session
nope nope nope nope I'm done I've tried
to go around but this has happened the
ODU ladies get the more you get set in
your ways book a session because I don't
want to do this in public man because
you seem like a sweet woman but you
don't but you're not getting it you're
being so mean I'm not being don't tell
me I'm being mean
I'm about to be mean I get tired of you
broads telling me I'm being mean because
you cannot handle a goddamn truth you
called my show on the day the training
was supposed to be here and I honored
the call and sat here and tried to help
you and I'm telling you telling me I'm
being mean the [__] out my phone
she didn't know she was about to be a
viral sensation
oh
so what'd you guys think Kevin Samuels
you can take off the headphones we're
done with the I think not everyone would
be able to take his criticism because of
how much it triggers whatever
he's directing his opinions at mm-hmm
this is very hard pill to swallow where
we've come in society is like it's it's
what Kevin Samuel represents is
traditional households traditional
relationships I feel like we have
strayed way way past that yeah what do
you think works better
modern or traditional typically
from what I've seen traditional usually
works out and but again it's it's a hard
pill to swallow and people don't
unfortunately want to hear the truth but
I gotta play the game man it is it is
what it is you make your bed and I'm
gonna Read Super chats real quick
um
we have 838 people watching in the chat
um it seems like most women want to mail
clone of themselves also guys they've
been calling my followers brokies
so I appreciate the super chats because
I'm tired of them I'm tired of these
these women not them
these women these women saying saying
that you guys are brokees you know damn
well you're not broke guys are dumb try
this after a few drinks oh they're
saying he still would you just gotta get
him drunk no
uh that would be how can you be logical
that would be me abusing him yeah that
wouldn't be like yeah you know what I'm
saying you know then I'm just playing
the sound okay
wait I want to go to the Super Chat for
Canada
they're not doing
her in a supers there we go
all right
um it seems like my guys aren't dumb and
marriage do women want peace or do they
want to be right all the time
chick has yet to give a straight answer
I finally disagree with pearl she's cute
with the hairstyle and I'm not a simp oh
look at they said keep it they said keep
it uh the blonde uh this chick has yet
to get a straight answer bruh oh wait no
no the
the blonde has to they're disagreeing
the blonde has to go young lady men
don't like it uh Pearl I hope you saw
that Viral Twitter post from the newly
married woman who said her husband is a
virgin and she has to go out to God to
erase the memory of all the men she had
slept with why would a 30 to 40 year old
man who makes good money risks trying to
impregnate a 30-plus young woman when he
gets plenty of opportunity from women in
their 20s silent sandwiches sex
um happy sammy wait until you show up
wait until they show you their serious
to give up value yourselves if you don't
value you they won't either modesty
agreeable think Doug if you navigate
life like a single woman no one is going
to stop you ladies no man is going to
break down your walls or understand your
past traumas
um by the way if green if green eyes
girls Cooks bingos I accept her as a
true chef and um in the in U.S I'm a
Brokey in Poland I'm middle class take
care girls Isaac a key that opens many
locks is a master a lock that open as
many keys is useless Lawrence why would
they date a man would they date a man
that went through a gay phase
um yes you would yes or no no thank you
I think yeah I wouldn't either
Pearl Pearl is converting one hoe at a
time sorry guys women
um they also often need social approved
before they're interested in a man
that's why a man with a high body count
is not the same as a woman with high
body count Pearl Andrew huberman and
Sarah go something about birth control
Pearl pull up techman study for sex
partners in marriage um Janome you know
global warming is bad when there are
more whales on land than in the water
what happened to your girl
for also the lovely ladies Texas Jeff
younger cases Lawrence gang bangers
Thugs and drug dealers don't seem to
have a problem finding love Charlie
normalized adoption I second to watch to
like watch said Doug only women can be
delusional like her men can't uh Pearl
could be either could be who knows Pearl
all YouTubers have a member oh okay we
read those ready
um okay guys thank you so much for I
think you guys are good sports today so
um do you have fun did I traumatize you
the review no I think it was a good okay
yeah I'm good you're good I just you
better not sometimes it's good to have a
conversation with someone's not yelling
in your face it's like a good yeah Good
Vibes right yeah right yeah tell that to
the the London hate anyway
guys um
um sign up for um the forms sign up in
the forms in the description we're
trying to find a way that crazy people
don't come to these meetups but I want
to do it in the next like two weeks so
make sure you sign up now I'm gonna get
on crazy yeah I'm gonna have security no
weird stuff no weird stuff but I'd like
to set people up I'd like to go to cool
places thank you guys so much for the
super chats I will talk to you guys next
time like the video on your way out
goodbye
[Music]